[Music]
with a box-office takings of just about
746 million u.s. dollars the first part
of Suicide Squad
stabler ranked in the top 10 of the most
successful films of the year in its year
of release
just behind Deadpool so that a second
part will be released was only a
question of time but after the
relatively unsuccessful spin-off birds
of prey the question now arises to what
extent this will influence the Suicide
Squad in the following video we will try
to give you a short overview about the
current state of the production the cast
and the story so the first question that
comes up is to what extent the cast of
the first movie also matches the sequel
it should be noted that margot robbie
will return is Harley Quinn Jai Courtney
as Captain Boomerang Joel Kinnaman as
Rick flag and Viola Davis as Amanda
Waller also on board are actors Nathan
Fillion Taika Waititi Peter Capaldi and
even wrestler and actor John Cena
therefore the Suicide Squad won't be a
complete reboot as the characters from
the first part do show up but according
to the information available so far they
will only be minimally linked to the
predecessor DC fans who didn't find
Jared Leto's Joker convincing can also
be reassured since Leto will definitely
not return to his role Jared Leto who
had expressed great interest in the role
of Joker will be busy with his role as
Michael Morbius for Marvel for the time
being anyway also Will Smith will not
return in his role as Deadshot the new
characters that will appear in the
Suicide Squad are mainly ratcatcher king
shark polka-dot man and peacemaker red
catcher
aka Altis Flanagan is actually male in
DC Comics but according to rumors he
might be female in the Suicide Squad the
ratcatcher is a highly criminal opponent
of Batman in Gotham City and gets his
name from his former work as an
exterminator the rat catcher special
ability is his communication with small
rodents that can come to help him
furthermore the rat catcher is supposed
to have no scruples when it comes to
using poisonous gases the polka-dot man
is in no way inferior to the red cat
he's also one of the biggest enemies of
Batman his name comes from his
appearance because he has polka dots all
over his body which can turn into
fireballs and other weapons the
peacemaker
aka Christopher Smith is officially as
the name suggests a kind of peace
activist who's extremely pacifist
he loves peace so much so to say that he
would kill for it according to many
rumors John Cena is supposed to take
over this role although neither Cena nor
gems gun have confirmed this at least as
important as the work in front of the
camera is the work behind the camera of
course and no one less than guardians of
the galaxy director James Gunn will take
over the director's chair
the director is currently working for
both Marvel and DC and is supposed to
bring fresh air to the new Suicide Squad
concerning the story there is almost
nothing known at the moment but we allow
ourselves some speculations one of the
theories is that James Gunn plans to let
almost all known faces die on screen at
the beginning of the movie this is
supported by the fact that gun when he
posted the cast on Twitter remarked that
we shouldn't get too attached to the
actors a comment by John Cena who said
that the first 10 minutes of the Suicide
Squad are a film on their own also
speaks for this
moreover the Hollywood Reporter said
that James Gunn's film will be adapted
from John Ostrander and Kim yells 1980s
comics rather than the new 52 version of
David Ayer's predecessor according to
actor Joel Kinnaman the Suicide Squad
will have a great amount of humor he
even went so far as to say that he feels
like he's starring in his first comedy
film the bottom line is that the Suicide
Squad will definitely be different than
the first part in addition a few days
ago various pictures from the set were
circulating on the Internet in these
pictures you can see Harley Quinn and a
blood red dress and moreover you can
also see the characters ratcatcher polka
dot man and most likely king shark who
is wearing a motion capture suit for
digital post-production the Suicide
Squad will be released on August 6 2021
and of course we will keep you updated
on further news as always
[Music]